[Musique]
bonjour à tous on se retrouve pour un
nouveau numéro du 7 8 dossiers
ce mois ci la rédaction de tv 60,18 vous
propose une série de reportages
consacrés à la gendarmerie nationale des
yvelines
[Musique]
les gendarmes assurent la sécurité des
français au quotidien est parfois au
péril de leur vie
c'est le cas du colonel de gendarmerie
arnaud beltrame décédé suite à une prise
d'otages dans un supermarché de la
banlieue de carcassonne le 23 mars
dernier dans les yvelines près de 650
militaires sont rattachés au groupement
de gendarmerie de versailles
ils interviennent principalement en zone
rurale pour des situations d'urgence
pour faire de la prévention ou encore de
la dissuasion
mais pour commencer je vous propose de
plonger au coeur de l'investigation
scientifique avec la cellule
d'identification criminelle
un montage signé jules grevy
accidentelle ou criminelle c'est la
question pour ces deux techniciens
d'identification criminelle de la
gendarmerie nationale des yvelines
accompagné par un pompier spécialistes
ils recherchent des indices dans cette
maison 24 heures après l incendie
objectif découvrir la cause du sinistre
pour nous c'est pas les criminels
donc on a inspecté les gravats quand je
vous disais tout à l'heure il n'y a pas
d'odeur d'accélérant de carburant ou de
matières suspect après un premier bilan
avec le pompier cette intervention est
terminée pour les techniciens
d'identification criminelle
les plus connus sont de miami ou de
manhattan mais les experts sont aussi
dans les yvelines
cinq techniciens au sein de la cellule
d'identification criminelle de
versailles la majorité de leurs
activités trouver des indices à travers
des méthodes scientifiques pour aider
les enquêteurs notamment sur des
homicides
donc là on a fait une représentation
d'une scène une découverte de cadavres
donc les premiers arrivés souvent sont
les voisins qui sont en galère que les
services de gendarmerie ou les services
de secours
une fois que l'on intervient la première
chose que l'on va faire c'est figé la
scène à l'aide d'un appareil photo
numérique
on va faire ce qu'on appelle une
triangulation prendre sous différents
angles la pièce et ce qui s'y passe
histoire de la figer dans un deuxième
temps on va faire un ratissage de cette
zone de la pièce entre autres pour
pouvoir marquer à l'aide de numérotation
les traces et indices qui nous
paraissent pertinentes et qui ne
pourront permettre de résoudre
éventuellement l'enquète ou en tout cas
nous permettre de faire parler les
indices en des indices sur des objets à
travers des empreintes digitales
retrouvées grâce à des poudres ou des
pinceaux mais aussi des prélèvements
biologiques pour retrouver de l'adn
je vais donc imbibé est couillon à
l'aide d'une petite goutte d'eau stérile
là je passe sur toute la zone où
potentiellement la personne à apposer
ses lèvres qui les lèvres dit ça livre
qui lie salive diadème autre type
d'intervention
les cambriolages ou les vols ici une
plaque d'immatriculation d'un véhicule
dérobé vient d'arriver au laboratoire il
va être analysée donc à l'aide de cette
machine l'acculent de fumigation on va
placer notre objet dans la cuve
là d'un produit spécifique on va passer
sous la coupelle nous allons le placer à
l'intérieur et lancé son cycle un cycle
qui dure à peu près une quarantaine de
minutes et qui va nous permettre de
révéler non s'il ya des empreintes
digitales sur le support une fois la
réaction chimique effectué l'objet est
amenée en selle d'optique
une fois qu on a appliqué notre
colorants on passe notre objet soudan
photos à l'aide de l'appareil que vous
voyez ici qui va donner une intensité
lumineuse et appareils on a un filtre
sur l'appareil photo
ça va permettre et d'exciter le support
et donne une luminescence de l'empreinte
digitale quand on éteint la lumière de
la pièce on voit apparaître clairement
la révélation d'empreintes digitales en
2017 56 dossiers ont été traités dans le
laboratoire de la cellule
d'identification criminelle 170
gendarmes de brigade sont formés dans
les yvelines pour relever des empreintes
ou de l'adn sur des situations de petite
délinquance
[Musique]
pour lutter contre le vol des engins et
accessoires donc il convient notamment
de ne pas laisser les clés sur le
contact du véhicule de ne pas non plus
laissé dans l'habitacle de bloquer le
volant avec un antivol mécanique des
conseils qui paraissent logiques mais
encore trop peu appliquées au quotidien
rené est là pour prévenir la délinquance
en analysant les situations à risque
aujourd'hui rendez vous à la ferme de
coubertin de saint rémy les chevreuse on
a eu un gros événement ici c'est un
incendie et donc suite à cet incendie
je les ai conseillé pour mieux sécuriser
pour mieux mettre en sûreté
leur exploitation agricole donc aussi
bien la partie bâtimentaire de véhicules
que effectivement la partie commerce
un incendie à l'été 2016 après un bilan
global le référent sûreté à proposer
différentes solutions aux agriculteurs
l'exploitation a donc débuté la
construction d'un mur de séparation
nous avons effectivement travaillé avec
le propriétaire des lieux pour que le
hangar ne soit pas coller à l'habitation
et pour qui une séparation visuelle
entre le matériel la spa ce matériel des
engins et le fourrage mais quelques
points sont toujours à améliorer
c'est avec isabelle qu'aux exploitants
de la ferme que le gendarme poursuit sa
visite il conseille de mettre les anges
en sensible plus en retrait parfois fort
et juste repenser réorganise
effectivement le reboucher oui voilà les
mots là parce que des fois la perte du
temps de soir à éviter effectivement
peut-être le vol de la nuit éclairage et
détection de mouvements à proximité des
zones sensibles panneaux dissuasifs et
construction du mur et des assurances et
du département la ferme a investi entre
vingt et vingt-cinq mille euros pour sa
sécurité
suite aux conseils du référent
régulièrement ils viennent nous voir de
toute façon il passe
ils passent dans la boutique où il passe
voir mon frère qui est plus dans
l'exploitation dont la des très bons
contacts avec eux pour justement nous
protéger au maximum et protéger toutes
les personnes qui viennent sur
l'exploitation la prévention en milieu
agricole de manière générale soit
différent type de vol les vols d'animaux
l'an dernier dans le département dix
mille personnes particuliers entreprises
ont été sensibilisés par ce service
actuellement les yvelines compte deux
référents sûreté un troisième est en
formation
votre nom je sais comment voyez-vous
votre prénom
vous ne touchez à rien je ne donne pas
trop bien tout se joue en l'espace de
quelques instants pour réunir les
informations nécessaires et engagée si
besoin une ou plusieurs patrouilles ici
au centre d'opérations et de
renseignement de la gendarmerie 150 à
200 appels sont gérés par jour plusieurs
personnes sont ainsi présentes sur place
pour répondre aux yvelinois qui compose
le 17
et gérer des cas qui peuvent varier du
simple accident domestique aux
agissements les plus graves
on peut aussi avoir des gens qui sont en
urgence parce que ils sont sur le point
de se faire assassiner ça a été on a eu
ce cas là une femme qui s'effectue en
direct par exemple eh bien on a eu la
chance de pouvoir lui demander où est ce
qu'elle était et qu'elle a donné elle a
donné sa position
en fait on est arrivé c'était trop tard
mais
mais l'auteur était resté sur place
était son mari en l'occurrence on peut
aussi avoir des gens qui sont tout
petits des enfants ou des personnes plus
âgées où il faut parler plus fort ce
qu'ils entendent par la catho
au total dix huit gendarmes se relaient
jour et nuit pour assurer le
fonctionnement du centre d'appels parmi
eux le chef fabien p o
alors le civet qu'est ce que tu m'as dit
que tu avais comme une peugeot 309 c'est
ça pour être opérationnel il a dû suivre
une formation et développer de nouvelles
capacités faut avoir un sens de l'écouté
il faut avoir une certaine une certaine
rigueur dans la retranscription des
événements et il faut avoir un certain
sang-froid de telle sorte à ce qu'on
soit pas embarquer entre guillemets par
l'affect de la personne qui nous
appellent équipes tremblent panique
tous les personnels ont déjà un vécu
déjà avant on a tous été en brigade
donc voilà on comprend pas des jeunes
sortis d'école il ya déjà un passif
faire passer tous les personnels ici ont
un sang froid et surtout se mettre dans
leur bulle quand il on l'appelle l'appel
justement celui ci ne dépasse pas
généralement plusieurs minutes
une série de questions simples et
basiques permettent de faire un état des
lieux et de mesurer la gravité de la
pelle ce premier contact permet aussi
d'assurer la sécurité des forces de
l'ordre engagé sur place et nous on a
une difficulté de perception des
événements
ça peut avoir d'assez lourd de
conséquences sur les victimes mais ça
peut être ça peut avoir aussi d'autres
conséquences plus lourdes sur les
personnels de secours qui vont
intervenir l'an passé le centre
d'opérations et de renseignement de la
gendarmerie de versailles a reçu près de
110 mille appels ceux ci ont entraîné
l'intervention d'une patrouille dans un
cas sur trois
[Musique]
et pour terminer cette édition consacrée
à la gendarmerie nationale nous vous
proposons une rencontre animal fidji
c'est la chaîne des gendarmes qui est
spécialisé dans la détection de
combustible utilisé dans les incendies
criminels un sujet signés camille
lambert toujours plein d'entrain pour
aller travailler fidji prend son rôle
très à coeur
aujourd'hui sur le camp militaire de ben
séance d'entraînement après qu'un
collègue est posée différents produits
s'est elle de jouer
allez on y va pas bouger tu attends une
minute alors tu cherches
il ne faut pas plus de quelques minutes
à la malinoise pour marquer
l'emplacement voilà si fidji est aussi
enthousiaste c'est parce que pour elle
il s'agit d'un jeu et pourtant son
travail est très sérieux elle détecte
les produits utilisés lors d'incendiés
criminels alcool à brûler white spirit
ou essence rien n'échappe à son flair
quel que soit leur état
il ya un produit qui a été brûlé un
produit qui a terrassé à l'eau est un
produit qui est resté nature pourquoi
ces trois états parce que quand tu sais
on a mis le feu ben les produits ont été
brûlées donc ce qui altère et ce qu'ils
changent leurs odeurs et sur le causse
l'opposition quand les pompiers sont
arrivés ça a été lavé donc pour
apprendre le chien a travaillé sur du
produit brûlé sur du produit la lave et
suite à une intervention des pompiers et
sur la matière à une attaque la toile
poissy trouver le produit qui n'a pas
encore été brûlés
comme elle ils sont une dizaine dans le
pays une spécialité unique en ile de
france qui vaut à fidji des opérations
régulières
cette année elle a participé à 19
interventions avec son maître une équipe
complices car la chaîne de 7 ans a
parfois ses humeurs yves est l'un des
rares à pouvoir l'amadouer et surtout la
comprendre ouf
ou si vous donnez sur papa car oui c'est
mon chien oui je travaille avec elle
c'est pas communauté de travail parce
que si on utilise notre chien que comme
un outil de travail bas moment donné ça
va pas mal ça va pas aller donc c'est
vraiment le binôme
je travaille avec elle j interprète en
langage humain ce que ce que le chien me
donne en langage un langage chien je
dirais elle me donne des indices son
chien moi je les traduis en langage
humain pour que mes collègues puisse
interpréter et puisse avancer sur leur
sur leur zone
un véritable duo formé pendant 14
semaines à gramat au centre national
d'instruction cynophile de la
gendarmerie iv fidji ont été accordées
selon leur caractère ne pas mettre un
chien qui va être hyper speed 1 m qui va
être calme et l' inverse
donc on essaie d'équilibrer sur les
caractères on est la seule
administration à le faire ça marche pas
mal du tout du début de mission jusqu'à
la fin de mission il faut qu'il
travaille avec la même motif d'une
motivation est le même le même entrain
un chien qui au bout d'une minute de
travail va tout laisser tomber parce
qu'il en a marre
nous ne nous intéressera pas donc le jeu
ça peut s'apprendre un chien la
persévérance au jeu c'est inné soit ils
assoient il n'a pas les missions qui se
termine toujours par une récompense un
moment de jeu avec son maître fidji
devrait servir encore jusqu'à ses 12 ans
elle aura ensuite droit à une retraite
bien méritée la gendarmerie recherche
toujours des chiens pour renforcer son
équipe
[Applaudissements]
merci de nous avoir suivis si vous
souhaitez revoir cette émission en
replay rendez vous sur le site internet
tv 78 ou notre application mobile on se
retrouve le mois prochain pour
l'ouverture d'un nouveau dossier
[Musique]